jurassic world dominion has finally
roared into theaters but how does it
stack up to the rest of the jurassic
franchise and which new character
totally steals the show keep watching
for the best and worst dominion has to
offer
one of the biggest selling points of
jurassic world dominion was a reunion of
the original cast it's the first time
all three original cast members have
been in the same film since jurassic
park famously sam neil and laura dern
sat out 1997's the lost world jurassic
park as jeff goldblum's ian malcolm took
center stage while neil and dern came
back for jurassic park 3. to be fair
it's true that goldblum had a quick
cameo in fallen kingdom the second
jurassic world movie however he didn't
interact with the main cast at all and
was only in bookend scenes so that
hardly seems to count there is an
undeniable palpable nostalgic thrill in
seeing them together on the big screen
again after nearly three decades apart i
could use your expertise
there's no way around it pratt's wannabe
rogue adventurer cliche owen grady has
always been one of the worst elements of
the jurassic world films the character
itself an archetype of the man's man
cool guy doesn't really fit alongside
the more every man heroes from the
original trilogy
here's the alpha
you're looking at him kid
in fact those characters are more heroic
precisely because they're not highly
trained with military backgrounds but
still nonetheless rise to the challenge
to fight and survive anyway there's an
element to the originals that due to the
character's relatability puts the
audience in their shoes and lets the
viewer imagine how they themselves would
respond to the extraordinary
circumstances it adds stakes and tension
that a generic action hero simply can't
deliver worse pratt simply doesn't sell
tough guy well while he did bulk up for
zero dark 30 and was an ostensible
action lead in the guardians of the
galaxy at avengers films his persona was
still that of sarcastic goofball in fact
the guardians movies go out of their way
to deflate pratt's peter star-lord quill
character at every opportunity treating
him as a parody of the tough 80s action
heroes he saw on earth before being
abducted
while it's cool that dominion finally
brought the old gang back together for
one last dinosaur adventure it is
newcomer dewanda weiss as kayla watts
who steals the show honestly it's a
shame she couldn't have been the main
character of the film watts plays a
jaded roguish pilot who is embedded in
the underground world of transporting
black market dinosaurs beyond dewanda's
natural charisma and the character being
cool throughout she also has a great
character arc to boot the actual
protagonists played by pratt and bryce
dallas howard don't really have any
internal struggles to grapple with all
their struggles are external like trying
to save their adopted daughter and
neither do the original jurassic actors
dewanda's watts however has to actually
grow and change in the story going from
cynical and brow beaten to courageous
and crusading sure it's a bit archetypal
but at least it's something simply put
she has the best lines the best
deliveries is seemingly having the most
fun and gets to experience growth when
she receives a new plane at the end of
the film it might be the single most
emotionally satisfying moment in all of
dominion
a major plot component of dominion is
that campbell scots dr lewis dodgson and
his corrupt genetics company biosyn have
been using prehistoric dna to
genetically alter locusts in an effort
to control and monopolize the food
supply chain they do this by unleashing
giant locusts to eat all the grain from
farms that don't buy biosin proprietary
seeds since the locusts have been
modified to not eat crops from the bios
and seeds this is how all three of the
original jurassic park characters get
involved in the story ellie sadler is on
a mission to expose biosin and its
genetically modified locusts since the
disruption of the food chain could cause
global starvation which dodgden sees as
a small sacrifice in maximizing the
company's profits she then enlists the
help of dr grant who both meet up with
ian malcolm who was employed at bioson's
secret facility the issue is that there
are just as much if not more action set
pieces involving the characters escaping
giant locusts then there are of them
dealing with dinosaurs you know the
thing audiences bought their tickets to
see while there are some interesting
ideas within the locust subplot it
overwhelms and devours run time that
should be devoted to dino action
like all jurassic park films the most
fantastical element of dominion isn't
the fact that dinosaurs are now walking
the earth no the real fantastical
element of jurassic park films is that
evil corporate ceos and their businesses
eventually get their comeuppance and
have to pay for their crimes it's a
satisfying fantasy manifested in the
original jurassic park novel onwards the
stories have always had an
anti-capitalist or at least
anti-corporate stance colin trevorrow's
jurassic world films are no exception
corporate villain dr louis dodgson is at
least partially based on elon musk
including a reference to his ill-fated
hyperloop and looks quite a bit like
apple ceo tim cook life in jurassic
world seems to imply that unethical
billionaires and hyper capitalists could
get their lives majorly disrupted for
their crimes at any moment perhaps dna
splicing isn't such a bad idea after all
bringing back the original cast is a
welcome move and a huge nostalgia rush
not to mention an excuse to watch great
actors playing iconic characters
unfortunately the overly reverent tone
of the world films can become grading
there's also cringy callbacks like a
repeat of must go faster when malcolm
gets into a car or when a character
tells him to close his shirt since his
chest in the first jurassic park became
a meme among many many others even the
romance of grant and sadler alluded to
and implied in the first film plays out
like overwrought fanfiction grant
sputters around ellie like a nerd trying
to woo the cheerleader at his high
school if neil or dern were lesser
performers it could have stopped the
movie in its tracks
in 1993 jurassic park was at the cutting
edge of modern paleontology before
dinosaurs had been depicted as slow
lumbering and entirely reptilian the
revolutionary theory that dinosaurs
evolved into birds was pretty new and
still in its relative infancy when
jurassic park was released and even the
word raptor means bird of prey
however the original theories that were
groundbreaking in the early 90s have
since become outdated this includes
substantial new evidence that dinosaurs
were probably in fact feathered rather
than scaly this introduced a problem for
the rebooted jurassic world series which
was being developed after these theories
of feathered dinosaurs became widely
accepted in the science community do you
keep the dinosaurs looking as they did
in the earlier films with their iconic
and highly merchandizable designs or do
you try to do what the first film did
and exist on the cutting edge of
paleontology while the first jurassic
world decided to go with classic designs
in dominion feather dinosaurs are on
display for die hard dino fanatics it's
as big a thrill as anything else in the
film
what the jurassic world series of films
promised and especially what the end of
falling kingdom promised was a world
overrun by dinosaurs yet the entire back
half of dominion is set in dodgson's
secret biosin facility and it is one of
the biggest issues with the film true
there are some decent set pieces out in
the supposed dino-infested world but by
and large the main bulk of the action
takes place in the aforementioned biosin
genetics facility at least it's not
another secret isla nublar site or theme
park but in many ways the sterile
silicon valley inspired lab environments
and dominion are somehow less
interesting it's all just white bland
corridors it's slightly better when the
characters are running around outside
the facility but since this is
surrounded by an artificially grown
prehistoric jungle full of swamps caves
and giant trees it might as well just be
isla nublar the jurassic world films
took two entire movies to get to the
point where dinosaurs have finally
reached the mainland wreaking havoc on
civilization now they're here and aside
from the malta chase scene and various
black market dinosaur operations very
little of the film expands upon a
premise which once seemed so promising
the scenes where the film works best are
when it's showing how the world has
changed whether it's a construction crew
having to use flares and equipment to
lead a wandering dinosaur away from
their site someone lassoing a dino on
horseback or a mosasaurus overturning a
fishing boat those are the scenes where
the movie shines
despite the mediocrity of the rest of
the film a beautiful ending montage is a
sight to behold there are the
triceratops marching with elephants in
africa soralophus galloping with horses
in the midwest a mosasaurus swimming
next to blue whales children feeding
copies like ducks in a washington dc
park and more it's all beautifully shot
wonderfully scored and like the malta
scene a two rare scene that capitalizes
on the jurassic world premise what helps
set it apart from the more ominous
ending of falling kingdom is that
instead of showing the potential
violence inherent in the idea of
dinosaurs coexisting with humans it
focuses on the beauty and potential it
also underlines a main theme of the
films about how nature always finds a
way
the cloned human plotline introduced in
fallen kingdom was a late film twist in
dominion it wants to be the film's
emotional spine the movie suffers
because of it sure tying the cloning
tech into the creation of humans is a
clever idea but the problem with this
big swing is that it's a miss jurassic
films are about dinosaurs not the mama
drama of cloned humans
he created another
he made her again
some of this might be due to the
plotline's execution since isabella
sermon's maisie lockwood is essentially
the same as a regular person it's hard
to see her as anything that's special
especially when compared to bringing an
extinct species back to life in the
modern era she's the reason the world is
overrun by dinosaurs in the first place
and the series just awkwardly glosses
over that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]